AINSLEY: WITH A CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE ON THE WAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS EXPECTED TO SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TODAY THAT WILL
MAKE SURE ALL AMERICANS RECEIVE
THE VACCINE FIRST BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES BEGINS HELPING
OTHER COUNTRIES.
HERE TO REACT IS FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR
OF THAT GREAT BOOK RIGHT THERE
MAKE AMERICA HEALTHY AGAIN
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
HEY, DR. SAPHIER.
>> GOOD MORNING.
SO HOW WILL THIS WORK?
>> SO, THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED
TO SIGN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TODAY
WHICH REALLY JUST FALLS IN LINE
WITH HIS AMERICA FIRST
INITIATIVE THAT HE HAS BEEN
PUSHING ALL ALONG THERE SAN
INTERNATIONAL COLLABORATION
GOING ON RIGHT NOW KOVACH.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME COUNTRIES WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THE VACCINE.
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING THAT HE
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT OF ALL
THE VACCINES THAT THE UNITED
STATES HAS PURCHASED, THAT
AMERICANS WILL BE OFFERED THE
VACCINE FIRST BEFORE THEY START
DISTRIBUTING IT INTERNATIONALLY.
THE GOOD NUDZ NEWS IS UNDER
OPERATION WARP SPEED THE
PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY PURCHASED
OVER 200 PERCENT THE SUPPLY
NEEDED FOR AMERICANS.
SO THERE WILL BE EXCESS.
SO HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY AMERICAN WHO WANTS THE
VACCINE CAN HAVE IT BEFORE THEY
START WORKING WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BODIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
COUNTRIES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
VACCINES.
AINSLEY: REGARDING THE FDA
MEETING ON THURSDAY.
EVERY SINGLE DAY MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
DRAGGING THEIR FEET?
SHOULD THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS APROOFERRED PFIZER A FEW
WEEKS AGO?
>> THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
SOME PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW THAT DO BELIEVE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE FDA ARE DRAGGING
THEIR FEET.
THEY ARE SCHEDULED ON THURSDAY.
TO REVIEW THE EUA FOR PFIZER.
WE DON’T KNOW WHEN THEY WILL
GIVE US AN ANSWER WHETHER IT
WILL BE THURSDAY OR FRIDAY.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
MEETING ON THURSDAY.
YES, COULD THEY HAVE POTENTIALLY
MET SOONER?
POSSIBLY.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN REVIEWING THE
DATA AND BEEN ALLOWING FOR